everyone for today's live office hours
were joined by adora and Vito and I'll
leave it to them to introduce themselves
I am a partner at Y Combinator
previously I had a was a founder CEO of
a startup called homejoy say a virtual
guard I'm going to call like three
expert I was most definitely director of
product at Facebook done a couple
startups sold a couple in less than a
bunch load already nice to meet you
Rachel
good to meet you give me welcome so tell
us what you do
hi I'm we're working on admission is a
web application that offers high quality
personalized college admission advice
for high school student so is it is
there another person on the other end or
how does the key give a the most common
use cases how people use so students can
sign up for free and they will create a
profile the profile includes the
academic information including their GPA
test scores and also extracurricular
activities and the college goals for
example the colleges that they want to
get into and also the majors they're
interested in so once they enter the
data we generate an algorithm - we use
an algorithm generate the personalized
recommendations to them to help them
reach their goals using that sir who do
you want to use this the high school
students and their parents who more
specifically for those who cannot afford
private college counseling because that
is the price ranges from 4,000 to like
$40,000 per package I see and why would
they use this because in the US public
high school one counselor 491 students
and each student only get 38 minutes of
College advising per year so we want to
fill in the gap so they could get access
and we think that every student deserves
the help they need to get into college
is there one particular thing that they
really need help on because when I one
of the things I think a lot of people
when they buy books a lot of books about
his essays because the application
itself it's pretty objective standard
right so do you find like there's a
specific feature that people are really
looking for and will actually pay for
interesting when we first started we
kind of just pretty bras we talked about
an essay we talked about college
selections but recently when we talked
to some of the users we found out that
they want one-on-one interactions and
specifically on college selection and
the essay so are you building a
marketplace them no this is people so
when we first started we just connected
on our own so I stepped back in this us
but actually we talked to Anton our
mentor on the school and and we also get
some feedback from users saying they
want in one-on-one interaction so last
weekend our team spent 30 hours to build
to go and launch that marketplace and
how's that going it's going quicker than
I expected so we sort of have three days
we have about 800 people visited the
site and then we had 60 about 60
advisers signed up so right now because
it's marketplace we focus on the supply
side first okay so your sixty advisers
how many and so you're focused on
acquiring those do you think that's
enough that seems like enough because
it's we're here Mindoro or there we go
[Music]
are you doing okay I can yell also there
yeah does it mean I get better it may
not have been on before so they're good
very good okay cool that's part of it
well so it's a supply-side acquisition
now if you have 60 advisers it looks
like you're ready to go then right yeah
you're ready to go but then we right now
our next step is to review those of
sizes and make sure that their profile
is nice and there are high quality of
counsel that will have specific
specialized certain areas so that we can
use those to actually at the students
why is now the right time to do this
like this could have been done five
years ago why is something changed in
the world that makes this possible now I
think that after industry I think we're
like slower than other consumer based
technology so I think right now is a
good time because the parents and
students they are getting more and more
tools in this school using technology to
learn like personalized learning and
collaborative learning so I think this
is space where it has not been fully
utilized yes what is it it is I think
the reason why is people usually they
focus really on tutoring they've put a
lot of those energy on to getting good
grades and then they feel like they know
exactly how they can get into college
just based on their friends and family
so they rely a lot of those personal you
know asides from their friends and
family or whoever I have gone through
that but we want to give them the
professional psyops thing it seems like
the amount of information out there is
out there and so people are trying to
probably differentiate themselves right
because everyone but like because
there's internet and I can get that same
access as personnel personally right and
so it makes sense that that you need
somebody also tell you like how to make
it better
versus just reading stuff but okay so I
want to focus on like seems like our
biggest challenge right now is going to
be matching right so you have sixty
advisers do you believe they're high it
sounds like you believe they're high
quality nuts right now to start matching
them so so how are you going to oh what
are your top two three determinants of
bringing on these advisors in so
definitely one of the things that we're
in for is you know whether the counselor
or the advisor is certified or licensed
so are the Jen you know we just launched
the market patients a few days ago what
we are going to do is to focus on those
profiles that are existing right now and
talk to the actual advisors to see if
they're you know they have to credential
how do you are you advisors yourself I
am sure you're on the site alright and
have you why don't I mean one thing
would be just to match people to you and
to figure that out apiece right so I
always start doing that I have one
person which I met in person because
they they basically just want to meet
with me in person does how we
we think that that is something that
will be valuable but we already stopped
putting myself out there into on the
supply side so there's there's a whole
set of product risk here which I think
hasn't worked through the thing I keep
coming back to is actually the market
risk on this one so my first startup was
an education so I know a ton about this
base actually and historically the
challenge has been that the way that the
average person in the u.s. thinks about
things like college missions is actually
pretty different than the way that
people are in this room probably think
about college education and
fundamentally a lot of that comes down
to do you think about education as an
investment or an expenditure and this
happens in a lot of markets where you
kind of build for yourself and then you
realize the market doesn't actually
behave the way that you behave and so
there's a leap that that sometimes
companies aren't able to make and so
that's why I was sort of probing on is
like has the market actually underneath
this changed like have you actually
validated that people want the same
things that you want and that that
market is large enough to actually
support a business well actually there's
reason change that I think will give us
an opportunity which is the new
administration because we're talking
about funding cuts into public school
systems so we were will expect that the
resources that they have will be less
and less and I think that is an
opportunity to educate the parents and
students and to promo the needs of
having the college advising
gotcha but they don't currently get it
today right they guess very minimal what
what resources do people have because
there's there's books there's like there
used to be sites like Volcom which I
don't think gives it gives its place
anymore so what are they using right now
right so there are a lot of free sites
out there like college sports and they
have checked at different website and
that's helped them the details of the
college's you know that probably the
application rate and all those stuff but
those are not personalized for them and
when we did an interview with the users
they found it very overwhelming to go
through all these different sites who
are they people that you were
interviewing where did you find this
we found it from all neighborhood
finally from our friends kids and
basically people that we know yeah I
think I keep coming back to this I think
specifically this is one of the biggest
risks in the education market is that
the the mass market is going to behave
differently than the than the people
that you know and so actually like
validating by talking to those people
what their needs are and what you want
to build for those people and what they
want is actually pretty critical early
on there's like people from your
neighborhood probably think about
education very similar the way you do or
your friends get spelling about
education very similar ways
yeah that's why ever since we launched
we try to iterate different ideas on the
decide to see which one catch more of
the attention I'm so finding we were
able to identify that one-on-one
personal personalized interaction is
important I think the next step we want
to drill down into something more
specific so that we can just focus on
that one thing
yeah have you guys considered the
international markets at all I guess
it's just a u.s. problem is this like a
global problem we thought about it there
are some leads that we talk to you there
is definitely the potential there for
international markets but you know the
platform that we have got out so far is
really targeted to us but you know that
doesn't really limitless on you know
expanding to more markets yeah have you
thought about going international first
as opposed to us first so our target was
basically States first there was a focus
and in fact you know our website is a
mission dot us so it's more like you
know um but you know definitely again
you know we do have we do know that
there are people out there you know
how's that of the United States you want
to study here in the state and they need
that information as well we talk to you
know advisors as well from outside of
the country there's the need but you
know we haven't we don't really have any
action item on like you know let's
target those market yet how many users
are on your site right now we have about
twenty two hundred students two hundred
students and where they what's the
common element amongst all of them so we
have forty percent of those a senior so
that tells me that they're pretty wait
they wait until for the last minute to
do this and then the twenty five percent
with junior and majority of them are
focusing on computer science and
engineering math type and business
majors
it sounds like you might want to I know
this kind of what I think retail is
getting at also is like trying to figure
out what is that core thing that they
really need versus this like right now
it seems a little abstract of I'm going
to help you find that college but it
might be at something as simple as the
essay like I need help on the essay and
just like just focus on that one thing
and drive it home versus being a little
bit you know doing so many things at
once so how many in submission is
basically to make sure that we are we
provide the same opportunity for all
students that chance to go into college
and we understand that you know
definitely within maybe California maybe
in bigger cities that you know people
students are more educated more they
have the background off you know what's
the path to college and beyond that what
we were trying to do again you know
going back to admission we want to make
sure that you know outside of these
group of students you know people from
our South California also have the same
access to the same information I mean if
you think about or actually you know
based on our survey or talking to users
we we know that a lot of students
actually think they might not even have
the chance to go into colleges because
of you know Ed's it's really it might
not be affordable to them right but
there's definitely you know alternatives
for them like you know financially and
things like and that's that you know
just appear that we're trying to target
to make sure that they have access to
that information so that they know they
at least have the chance to you know
apply to college and maybe you know
qualify for financial aid and you know
path that I can go and are things I love
what you said by the way like that's an
awesome mission right so there's when
you think about a company there's like
the mission there's the visioning like
when we achieve the mission here's what
the world will look like there's the
strategy just like here's how we're
going to hear in the fewest number of
words how we're going to go about
achieving our mission and then there's
the tactics there's the things that you
do week over week in pursuit of your
strategy to validate whether the
strategy is true or not I think the if I
said it or is giving is more like
strategic advice just like okay great
that's an awesome mission but where do
you start
what is the first value you create for
people and then that lets you create
that second value in the third value and
then you've created all of the value for
that popular
people where do you start yeah if you
think about if you're on apply to
college there's many steps in that and
you can't tackle every single step so
find the one and what you people are
having the most issue with or they need
the most help in which they will
actually pay for as well can you're
trying to obviously build a business
right and I just started to get but
there's not just product raters also
they go to market strategy which is like
that's a lot of people right
what is how many people feel like 50% of
people even take the SAT in the US right
it's like taps people don't even take
the SAT right you're talking about large
numbers of people at every step of the
funnel and so who you target is also
part of your strategy and who your
target is going to be directly tied to
what you build for those people as a
first step
yeah I think that's a great point and
when we first started there are like
many different angles we can target and
we want to use the state users data and
we want to just ask users to drive us to
which is the focus and I fell it because
the early acquisition is really hard
like for the users so I don't have
enough people to actually give me
feedback on which areas they want to
focus on some early indication is school
selection and essay so these are the two
that so if I can identify some major is
I science math and business so in the
subscreen majors so we have some pieces
of signals that tell us which way we
should go but I know in my heart that
going forward there's some one area that
I need to focus on I feel like we don't
have enough data to get there yet yeah
well the the challenge of data is this
goes back to like there's originally two
ways to figure it out I figure out what
you want to build but it's your market I
go to market plan your product is the
top down which is like you go get a
bunch of data where the opportunity is
how you slice the market we're going to
start here then we're gonna go here
where you here or bottoms up which is
you build the thing you put it out there
people start using it so I go we want
this we move forward and and a lot of
software actually bottoms up is great
because the early adopters indicate
where the world is headed and so you
build for them and then the rest of rule
kind of catches up it's like social
networking obviously was a great example
of that the challenge is if the people
are the early adopters of your product
are not representative of what everybody
else is going to do then you end up
building a thing that doesn't actually
work for everybody else and that's I
think part of the challenge of you have
right now if you do that is I suspect
the people that are coming to you are
not going to be a hundred percent
presentative like to me sounds like two
different populations of people you're
talking about the people who don't know
about financial aid and maybe are not
applying to colleges and not doing all
these concepts we don't have the support
versus like people who are organically
finding this and care about the stuff a
lot like to me actually sound like
different populations of people okay I
think we just finish up but just one
last thing I might it seems like a lot
of people are coming to you for advice
anyway and I might just start from there
and just sit down with all these people
and just do it all day every single day
for the next I don't know few weeks and
then see if there are anything common
things that people are asking you all so
there you have six you have access to
now sixty advisers you could also sit
with them and do the exact same thing
it's totally not a scalable thing to do
in the future
but it seems like to figure out where to
start
that's like one way to go about doing it
thank you I may add or say the whole
creature thank you give me cool thanks
for coming thank you what are you guys
working on so I'm Sid and I'm the CEO
and co-founder of Ambo at the mo we are
bringing computer vision technology to
solve the price and cost estimation
problem for the home services market
specifically we are starting with the
moving industry so let's say you're a
consumer and you want to move and you
want to know how much it's gonna cost
you take a video and our technology will
identify all the items and then you get
a upfront and accurate code so this is
much better than calling multiple moving
companies staying on the phone for about
half an hour each to get arbitrary wrong
quotes or waiting at home for an on-site
estimator to come visit
so is this an app so we sure we have
multiple channels we did an MVP pilot
with an app we've also been working on
just having it directly on the webpage
of the movie I'm at home it sounds like
I take the app and I'm taking pictures
and I'm sending it to you guys and then
you kind of give me an estimate ASAP
essentially okay correct yeah we also
have a solution where you can text it to
a number but it's the same technology is
more accurate than
the or how what's the percent of
accuracy do you get they stop so someone
coming in so we are targeting the same
accuracy so so the way we are thinking
about it is today the estimation process
takes about a week for you to get a code
or you get multiple codes and you don't
really understand why a food is what
what it is so our goal is to give you
complete breakdown on what it is and we
still have some human labor in the
background cleaning up the mistakes the
AI is making so our goal is to reduce
the human time to less than five minutes
so why why is it so transistor why is it
so take a week to get a quote with we're
yeah we're moving tech coming things I
want
so what main reason is if you are
scheduling an on-site estimator visit so
it it costs the moving company a lot
more than $200 per visit and you have to
schedule something scheduled someone to
come visit and these guys are able to do
two to three estimates a day so in the
summer time and it's busy it gets really
backed up on the book so most companies
don't end up actually sending an on-site
estimator and they give price quotes
over the phone our research shows that
90% of these are strong so consumers
shop around and they don't really
understand why why a company's quoting
what they're coding and in a lot of
cases what happens is there are these
predatory providers in the market who
take advantage of this price of pigness
and they give you a lowball quote get
your business and on the day off you
move specifically they slap you with
last-minute fee hikes so we want to
bring your eliminate all of that and so
once you get the quote are you also
doing the moving yourself or are you
selling weed so our strategy that we're
working with moving companies to do the
estimating for them so we are not a
moving company and our customers we can
go say you're a white label solution for
them yes
okay why do you need computer vision for
this it seems like everything you
describe to me sounds like process
failures like transparency in a
marketplace failures like it sounds like
a bunch of yeah what does the computer
vision gave you so our initial MEP that
we deployed doesn't have any computer
vision people just take videos and
someone watches it in the back end and
to give a code that takes around the 90
minutes per person
so and also you need to hire and scale
human workforce to do that and there are
a few other companies that do it that's
doing this so our goal is we eliminate
like majority of the work through
through using CV and and keep the human
workflow to as as less as possible and
from a product perspective what we want
to be also able to deliver to consumers
there's a interactive eight of them
customizing their quote so let's say you
have a two thousand dollar budget and
and everything moving everything is
maybe going to cost three thousand
dollars then you can decide they can
choose how you want to spend that money
how do you intend to charge for this and
you have current customers right now ah
yeah so we we signed our first LOI for
repeat the trial with mowing company in
San Diego uh where we are doing this GPM
solution where it's ten dollars with no
AI and fifty dollars with AI and we are
talking to multiple large moving
companies from twenty million dollars
annual revenue to a few billion dollars
in and we are in the final stages of
negotiations with some of them on the
timelines as well as the features of the
of a paid pilot so it's like enterprise
level contracts that we're going after
so what does success look like for you
is it accuracy or what are the these
folks looking from you so two different
things from a consumer standpoint they
want to reduce the friction of they want
to provide a better quality of service
because there is no wait for the good
companies to differentiate themselves
right now so they are looking at it as a
better way to do customer service and
also from a cost standpoint since it
cost more than $200 as an on-site
estimator and it doesn't scale they're
looking at ways to increase their bottom
line in their profits I wonder if
there's a bigger market in you being the
initial base people thinking you're the
initial moving company or in your
selling the leads I don't know if you
want to get into the actual moving
itself and that seems quite different
it's just operationally headache but
instead like part of what you're doing
is also acquiring users and getting that
sales process going and making it a
great experience and if you do that
really well then why not just own the
entire process well make a fire sale
process that's something that we've
considered but moving has a lot more I
guess intricacies and just the code so
right now we're just hyper focused on
generating the best codes possible
that's something that we could possibly
do in the future and the second point is
you're not acquiring customers today the
moving companies acquire customers
themselves
so we we are a technology that either
they're on the website or they direct
the consumers to our ramp
why do you charge more for the AI and
West Philippine people so for with the
$10 solution the the assumption is if
you're the moving company you watch the
video and provide the code yourself so
so there's some human so the moving
company you have to hire people to
actually watch the video so you're not
hiring people to do it on the $10 know
who is actually taking the non-ai
version right now REI is not completely
ready yet so that's the product that we
are selling right now but why not so
just the a I mean that's what you're
going to be so why not sell the AI
product now and you could still have it
as a gift yeah thank you can we make it
you know so that's a good question so
it's two reasons the first one is if you
want to train Rai on real world people's
homes the like you can imagine when
you're moving your house looks nothing
like the beautiful cat elasticsearch
this is like a you need a lot of data
and to get a lot of data really quickly
you could just you know provide this
blanket solution and all the moving
companies think they're getting this
thing yeah so and you're providing same
amount of quality either way right yeah
so we are actually hiring annotators so
that are all sourced where s REI is
improving their workloads is reducing so
that's something that we're doing so
homes are very different and which is
why it's probably such a big problem you
know one has got figure out how to
standardize the quoting process how do
you how much data do you think you need
before you've gotten something that can
just run on its own
so we are actively also web scripting
formal data through Google from Google
Flickr so we have a few million shot
images already downloaded so the goal
the goal is again the day is the
accuracy keeps increasing with time and
as more consumers use it and we have a
fall I feel failsafe mechanism of humans
filling in the gaps in the meantime what
do you think your biggest what is your
biggest challenge right now that's a
good question so and it's one thing I
think startup school has actually helped
us out with so we are going after large
enterprise contracts and it's it's
taking some time because our AI is not
ready yet so we are looking at ways of
how to deploy a solution while
simultaneously being one can monetize it
as well so in the meantime because of
our our mentor from start of school we
are doing this GPM solution so that we
get our product out the door
we did a non-player non-paid pi a pilot
so this is a way to get some paying
customers so so anything that can reduce
the sales process especially as we're
going after the enterprise customers
would help us accelerate faster as well
as I guess in each other I clone
ourselves to how to create a product
that's much faster much accurate in a
shorter period of time
all right that right that it's
generating weed and then so what is your
pipeline look like how many companies do
you talk to a day sure so I said
mentioned we're targeting of initiatives
larger enterprises because that allows
us to scale faster so we found it's
pretty easy to get companies in the
funnel when you explain what you're
doing it's that the end of that after
you've shown them the tech you show them
the demo and we're ready to assign for a
paid pilot that a lot of folks are
saying this is great I needed to do
everything right now so there's a bit of
a gap between where we are today and
where we need to be where we could close
them a lot faster and that's kind of
where we're coming in with these
creative ideas of how do we monetize
what we have today and then work towards
that goal what does that gap exactly so
they want to full AI and just produce a
price quote correct yeah and you expand
this yeah so you can imagine that
we have about we're detecting about 40
objects today so we need to scale that
to 150 objects and because we're using
video we need to track these objects
across frame so we understand that this
is one chair even though I'm seeing it
for from the fifth second to the 15
second so that we need to identify the
size of the object because that
contributes to cost as well so there are
multiple things that we are doing too so
we're working simultaneously and making
progress in all of these and are they
willing to sign otherwise I'd say like
hey if you have this we would give you
$10,000 a month or already sign I say
how many as always so we have more than
half a dozen of valois already signed so
we are still working on the contract
dollar amount with a few customers we
are in the final stages of find like
figuring out what that amount actually
is going to be how are you pricing that
so for the ones that you do have signed
have you priced it for the first year we
are we are pitching a flat fee so a few
hundred thousand dollars where they can
use their use our product as much as
they want where we actually work
together with them in in refining the
process of how consumers actually used a
user technology to get a code okay so
the total contract size or each contract
is worth a couple hundred thousand so we
are looking at signing a maximum of up
to three in the first year or a few
hundred thousand dollars okay so could
you can you just repeat the doors
earlier point can you just hire like two
people to do this full-time and go get a
couple hundred thousand dollars from
these guys and saying okay we have AI
that's as good as a human because you
literally have a human that's what
you're doing I mean that's that's our
that's our cool once we sign this but
they also want like more like a
turnaround time of a few hours
so that's something that we're working
with actually so that's a very good
point so what is your turnaround time I
guess you're optimizing for this at this
point yeah so it depends so we can have
our turnaround time as less as one hour
it just means that you need to make sure
that we have someone on call
huh 24 hours a day so when minority a
spits out the analysis variable 2 p.m.
you might actually just want to figure
out what the labor costs therefore now
as you're building up some data and then
just price accordingly yeah so it might
not be right now you're charging $10 or
something $50 yeah $50 and I'm white
right now due to the labor cost because
you don't have all the data it's not
accurate enough it might be a hundred
dollars yeah cost to you so why not just
charge something a little bit above that
it will knock out a number of you know
people who won't pay that much but at
least I'll get you going with real
customers so with the large enterprise
customers we are pitching a flat rate so
with the smaller guys here pitching the
ten dollars and fifty dollars just to
get more data to our pipeline but maybe
that's a good idea we know flat rate was
why you're pitching flat rate with the
big customers um because this is very
new to them and we want to make sure
that they are incentivized to choose it
as much as possible and and like
pitching on a purple you see we feel
like maybe do they already have
estimators could you're replacing them
in some sense down the road right so we
I don't think initially the target is
let's say you have like a five bedroom
or six bedroom house they may still want
to send an estimator over but there is a
significant maybe 75% of the cases where
they don't really send an estimator so
our so initially based on our
conversations they may start using us
for that specific segment of the market
before I started getting wood onto weeds
but one of the advantages are sending in
estimators you're also a salesperson and
so they close the sale for them and so
it might be that especially going to a
huge house that could be a lot of profit
for them they wouldn't even want to just
sits exactly around somewhere else so
maybe is you also this is a tool for
that estimator right to go faster and
they can get to more houses and then
yeah that's one of the options that
we're working with great one of these
companies ok conditioning so what is it
what does this become like suppose
you're successful you a bunch of
contracts than what happens so again we
started with moving but we've also found
opportunities and other parallel
articles like you know painting and home
renovations and so on so where the data
that they are collecting and the I would
actually training those will help us get
to a solution faster so so our goal is
solve the problem for one industry and
go horizontal to the second industry and
so on it seems like something like
painting would be easier yeah they're
just thinking exactly that's a square
footage it sounds like so a severe
problem yourself it's actually slightly
more difficult because if an on-site
estimator comes to to estimate your
painting area so there's like all these
furniture that's blocking the views of
the walls and so on so and also getting
scale it's important in in painting so
we need to get to the square feet level
so so so we looked at it and then we
found we thought that we think that the
bowing so easy problem to solve is
usually check technically single
technically speaking I think this is
such a huge business like if you guys
can eventually just solve the estimation
problem the pricing problem you solved
90% of the headaches that all these lead
generation home service lead generation
maybe yeah billion dollar this is like
huge is the next vehicle potentially
right so yeah Congrats you should apply
to YC yeah yeah looking forward to okay
[Applause]
hey Rachel
can we stop sweetie can you yeah so we
are Almo base also what we do is we help
schools will engage alumni communities
so currently schools have problem
tracking there Illinois wants to
graduate and alumni experience is very
broken like the moment to graduate they
keep getting this giving solid station
emails and nothing much
and then so with alma base what happens
is you can create a private alumni
network where your alumni can sign up
using the universal login slick face we
can LinkedIn and then they can engage
with each other for mentorships for job
opportunities or for signing up for the
reunions and such things and when the
alumni are engaging the school
would get insights like alright so how
how was this particular user engaging
like this alumni engaging with our
Facebook page how many times he has
liked us or how many times have
commented all such insights so that they
can prioritize their alumni and then
they can reach out to the right alumni
for different offshore colleges and how
cool yeah Cato independent schools and
universities do they all have the same
problems in terms of reaching out to
alumni uh-huh yeah so like the
universities definitely have a different
problem because there are a different
scale but schools have a different
problem the biggest problem with the
schools have is they do not have updated
alumni data because the moment to
graduate so it's just a basic but all of
you is currently just a basic CRM and
it'd be a hundred X better than what I
have kind of kind of but but the way
that they get the data into the CRM is
by the social media integration that's
the key value that we provide so the
moment you sign up we get your profile
information from Facebook allocation and
your employment your current location so
if someone has moved from like San
Francisco to Boston and they update it
on Facebook it automatically gets synced
here currently the way schools are
tracking it is by either putting up
google form on their aluminized tabs and
the school's website or by asking them
to email or doing photons which is like
so is that part of the problem is just a
connection to that person so once like
just emailing them and they actually
seen the email and then converting that
person yeah what it's quite difficult
like how many times you responded to any
of your school emails and then once you
get the input from the email then you're
going to need to put it in some other
database and and you always need to
manually update the database in excel
spreadsheet or something with that which
is a customer you focused on like right
now high schools or colleges like k12
high schools interesting yeah I'll let
you two been in once from from the from
the end user perspective why would they
want to sign up like they're having
snapchat and Instagram I Facebook
whatsapp
yes like messenger a phone and your
dress to slack and this yeah I got it a
lot of people ask me every day so but I
mean inside of school like in our matter
most group I just supposed to just say
how many of you want to like join a new
network of your alumni and why do you
want to join so everyone is like yeah we
want to have that private networks
because like
the link dance and the Facebook are like
public networks but they want to just be
inviting a lesser group just office the
Facebook group doesn't solve it because
like you cannot actually link to each
other for job or between sulfur
mentorships for one thing what you mean
why not sorry
why not can you can just message
somebody if you're in the same group um
no but but I mean how many times you
actually get those notifications like I
turn off a lot of my groups and then the
beach of the group is like 7% these days
because like Facebook really want to
like promote like ads or something on
the groups so it's quite difficult in
terms of that engagement in facebook
groups but why wouldn't the same thing
so if I follow your logic you basically
said you join a group you could
theoretically join a group yes then
people could reach out to you they can
like your stuff they can post a bunch in
the group okay and Facebook will notify
you because their stuff happening in a
group that starts to get annoying so you
turn off the notifications exactly why
wouldn't the same thing happen for you
yeah so here you can actually set up
different notifications like when
they're signing up we ask them like how
do you want to contribute back to your
community is it by mentorship or is it
by providing job sharing opportunities
or by giving a volunteering or planning
reunion
so ask those and based on that we they
can configure notifications and they
would be getting a digest based on this
note these settings I say yeah so you
wouldn't be getting like all the common
ones for example a class of 1990s having
a reunion and you're in the Stanford
group and you're from the class of 2000
then you actually don't want to see that
right I mean that's that's nice for you
it's not relevant for you in the group
how many family school do you have uh to
be precise ninety four and how many per
school alumni per school uh so on
average it's five thousand and it also
it goes to like fifteen thousand
depending upon the boarding school or
the kind of idea per five thousand one
night per circle
yeah are on your website you like yeah
having a su 94 but four hundred fifty
thousand you know we have around like a
million records like some schools how
more and we also have signed up some of
the universities and of that like 25
percent have signed up on the platform
just of them are still are yet to sign
up on the platform
alright I'm gonna sign up to the
platform so one thing is the admins like
the Alumni Relations Office they have
different to
like where they can post content and you
know a weekly digest goes so they come
and they consume this content or they
respond to any of the things like
there's a section called needs if
someone wants any help they can just
post there so they come and they respond
to this especially this is activity that
they do at this point of time
are there any job postings they just
come and apply they're looking for job
opportunities and so if I'm finally the
officer who is actually buying this
who's making the purchase cool is buying
it those who inside the school are the
other relations office not the
Association but the organization's also
every school have a development office
in which the relations officers like to
part of so they buy it okay how much how
are you pricing it's very stressful yeah
we are prising so we have three
different plans but the pro plan is
something which has like a lot of uh
features and it is like $5,000 per year
yeah per year yeah you know it seemed
like one to get these users it would be
right after they graduate yes but to
something I feel like the the missing
feature here something along the lines
school spirit I can't articulate right
now but this is what's not like I'm
trying to think what visual is I think
like try say is like a lot of what
you're building is already on Facebook
or these other things and people
naturally create these groups actually
and maybe it's not the entire school but
in their front set or you know like I'm
in a group of a hundred people high
school I think so
but what I I don't know I I don't know
I'm not sure where I'm going to right
now but I think like the way to capture
these people and the alumni folks the
administrators you can capture some kind
of school spirit thing where yeah come
back to the other side exactly so I mean
if you look at it the reason why you do
not want to give your contact
information is because the school is not
providing any value to you at this point
of time so but if they could like
provide some value hey there are like so
many mentors if you want any mentorship
can you just come here and you know we'd
be helping you and then there's there's
a student aspect like for example the
graduating class so like in the high
schools especially when they're going
for their college applications or
something in the counseling the
counseling officers in the schools they
can just match these people and then
help them get a better counseling
regarding their college so these kind of
small things that they can do at this
point of time which i think is not so
structured
in facebook groups or anything of that
sort and the key thing here is the
Alumni Office can take control of all of
this like what is the activity that is
happening which is not fun
what is success look like for the Alumni
aspect in a year they have to renew the
contract and buy again how do they
decide whether to give you another
process sure so I think it's about the
number of alumni that to sign up and
then the kind of enrichment that they
get in the data like for example one of
the schools so they have only like 600
records but the total aluminized centers
like 8,000 people so we also have an
invite tool where they can invite folks
wire Facebook and LinkedIn so now they
have like 1,800 folks in like first six
months yeah and why do they want those
records again like forgiving or for
knowing their preferences and engaging
them better and providing more value
what is it there's it sounds like
there's some downstream metric like
let's say I'm the Alumni Office and I
got all eight thousand records in the
database okay I'm the principal of that
school do I just fire the Alumni guys
that person's like not average I said I
got all he does records I think to place
where they were going to use it is for
example it's for mentoring which is a
huge value that you're like thinking but
even the Alumni officers are not really
up they do not know what are the key
metrics so we are also trying to help
them build those kpi's along the way
when they're working with it like the
answer would be somewhere along the
lines of donation yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's that's the end goal like a look
at a funnel so what are the tool then
you have to build on these tools right
so you got all these people in grades
yeah how are you going to get these
people to donate to donate so we had a
fundraising module where you know you
can put different campaigns like okay
this is the annual campaign to the
campaign for particular building and
then you can make donations on some
parties like it's not my son this so
that's the critical thing like the
alumni person is trying to figure out
how to get more donations ultimately why
do all this extra work to try to get
them like why not go through their
existing channels and help them optimize
what they're already doing sure so what
we've seen is when they're just doing
this load station for these donations
actually
the donation rate has come down like for
example in the schools so it has
actually come down when compared to the
Alumni like general users just donating
it to nonprofits so these days are just
relating to cause and not
the schools or anything of that sort
right so what we believe is like the
premise or the hypothesis that we have
as engaged alumni would eventually turn
out to be donors it's actually all of
this so you need to provide value before
and then ask them don't just ask them
ICN is there is there data from
something like this or software's been
around for a long time I asked imagines
here it's effectively CRM ah offer yeah
in the backend just yeah yeah but like
you know I get emails all the time from
from organizations that have been
involved with that try to engage me and
have programs and like is there data
that says yes if you engage your alumni
they will actually do any more I'm not
yet I mean we have really like for 18
months but no no but from other software
like there's mailing lists those are
people who are responding to mail
mailing lists like more likely to do so
that's what the school say at least like
yeah we haven't I mean I ask them like
who are your current donors so they say
yeah these are like alumni who are
engaged or who teaching or who come here
for guest lectures or who regularly
respond to our emails so but we do not
know the exact numbers but that's what
we get a sense of interesting is there a
reason why you started with high school
versus colleges because like colleges
has much bigger budget through this in
fact they have entire offices for this
yeah and then the alumni have more money
to make sure so is it the schools
I mean surprising the choice of the
schools but the reason why I mean we
initially went behind colleges but then
the sale cycles were really long like
there's a lot of decision making process
and then the procurement process and
some bidding system income and all the
money's at yeah you can eventually go
there really really go like one step at
a time so we are just but I think the
tool you build for high school alumni
administrators are much different than
the college really different yeah
eventually yes so so we are I think more
you're suggesting is go to just the high
school but really the northern I still
talk to you for 10 minutes so I want to
pivot the entire thing right now I would
really think hard about you know the
market opportunity between high school
and college no I agree that the market
opportunities huge with universities I
mean just a pure paperback map says that
but the only thing is it's a lot more
sales cycle and it's just tag knitting
you're close at this point of time
with with the schools they're like even
to two people in an office and if you
both agree to buy it and just buy it but
in a university okay
you are the Illuminations director and
your second director and you both agree
now you need to go to the Development
Director and then you need to go to the
VP of advancement the institutional
advancement and then the procurement
also once you figure out that sales
price process I know it's difficult I
want to figure it out it's probably
somewhere in all colleges you just
optimize that and get really good at it
and then all and then people will start
coming in faster right but it is a pain
to so you get it yeah so what is seen is
like for example there are other players
in this market so we have like I mean we
are we are just tracking of what rate
they're also closing the higher rate if
they're selling the eyelid and we are
talking to few people so they say like
it's eventually how much I don't know
whether they have really a crack the
process but they have like 9 to 12
months sale cycles it's like a long
relationship building process they
initially need to like meet the champion
then they need to cope with the Avensis
really really long the you know like
like a sales process yeah
now I mean it's it makes sense it makes
more sense the I think the risk really
is that you end up the thing that you
want for high school is actually very
different in you know for colleges sure
and so actually like you you have now
built a product for this market you
can't go to the more valuable market
like you end up in this niche that is
great because it's faster when that
niche sure but it doesn't translate to
the bigger more valuable niches like the
risk that your honor oh that's Reggie
not true but there is a slight role or
lap in the kind of tools that we're
building so I feel that you know once we
get some insights here and then we also
have like a couple of universities like
I think eight universities currently
using us so based on those insights like
we are keeping a close eye on them and
and depending on that once we build some
inner success stories with them I like a
case study then we have much better
social proof which might be helpful and
and optimizing the sales process I want
to start I think what this is what
vision was getting at earlier and you
know these people at the college is
they're very have a system in place I
can mailing-list marketing content and
stuff like that maybe don't ich li
replace all of it but maybe talk to a
bunch of these people and maybe you can
build tools to help them do something I
don't know what
is but somehow even better and then
start from there and it's not the one it
cost as much but it gets you in the door
sure sure yeah yeah well the other it
starts ticking us but for the other big
thing on it's everything you're saying
makes a lot of sense in the near term I
mean if you look at there's a great
story it's like with a very first banner
ad on the internet have like a
seventy-three percent click-through rate
or something and saying just go nobody's
ever seen a banner ad there okay what is
that every click yeah yeah and obviously
people won't click on banner heads
anymore I'm sure early facebook
notifications had crazy CTR and they
still have actually surprisingly good
secure and so the risk you actually run
is by trying to build your own
distribution channel that you end up
having the same thing happen to you a
couple years from now and they're doing
it in a tough spot but actually to me it
sounds like you're articulate it really
well is the crux of what you want to do
is help these people raise more money
and the channel is just a means to
helping them raise some money and
another way to attack it is like a cable
if you want to raise money what are the
10 things I could bill free that would
just raise the money rather than needing
the channel to raise the money which is
just one tactic so like like a pilot so
you know what I'm doing is I'm
volunteering with one of our customers
and the pay is cool who's doing the
specific fundraising campaign so we're
building some tools for them to
understand the exact problem like what
are these tools that are required for if
at all we need to just only sell the
fundraising aspect like do it for free
and maybe take a cut all right so which
makes the decision making process also
very easy so we are there volunteering
it kind of working and figuring out what
is there and what is there in
fundraising yeah so I maybe put it a
different way it seems like there are
already a lot of channels out there
between male email and Facebook and then
like whatever messengers attachment and
building yet another channel is it
creates a lot of product risk for you
okay but actually just helping them
raise the money better through the
channel that they're already trying to
manage would be a different way to
approach it and you might be able to
actually left a much bigger market sure
actually I have how I think that's the
biggest challenge that you are facing
also like so initially we built these
tools for the Alumni Relations Office
where you know they can in the back end
they can do all of this because they are
the one who is making the purchase at
the end of this so they need to
immediately see that instant
gratification over there and improving
their
look but getting the alumni to sign up
is a very is a big challenge like you're
mentioning so yeah that's that's a big
product challenge that we have like I
can imagine literally if you just made
it easy like I got some questions I
don't know you like you click through on
the link and you're like wow I'm trying
to give you money and you're making it
so hard like I can't do it on my phone
like it if forums they don't fill in
properly and then like be validating
properly from the JavaScript yeah I'm
trying to give you money like wisely so
why is this so yeah I can't imagine
literally you just the Alumni Office
would be so happy if their conversion
right from like 5 percent to 12 percent
they were just make more money yeah
exactly yeah that's what we were trying
all right cool I think that's it sure
[Applause]
yes sir yeah follow down a few days from
say for example our international
partners on their relationship and then
so we are not able to get close to our
users so what is the genic advice in
terms of like in that situation how do
you actually get to understand you users
better why are you not able to get your
users um so you're here right now right
yeah but after a point of time I need to
again travel back and then again come
and so we are like switching our roles
like three co-founders so each of us
come at different times and then we stay
and then we kind of work with the
schools but that has been ongoing
challenge for us I think are you at
least where you based akheon Morgan u9g
and who are your users that are
elsewhere up so there's different
schools right so the schools in Bay Area
and yeah
different different states sorry oh I
see okay well I mean I think you should
the main thing is the establishing
relationship with these folks and so
sitting down with them for a little bit
for I don't know a day or a week and get
you know the work for going is one way
to do it and then obviously you can't be
everywhere at once
but I think you build a lot of products
and you don't have to be right next to
them
I think there's like two general classes
to do this there's a qualitative and
quantitative on the qualitative you can
there's like all different scales you
can literally have one-on-one studies
are doing with users you can have a
forum we create online user feedback
software that will give you a bunch of
good qualitative feedback - people
upload something that gives you some
signal I've seen companies use what they
would call it a client council so you do
is you take like a representative sample
of twelve to fifteen people you bring
them in once a quarter once every six
months you show them new stuff their MD
aid they talk through it they give you
qualitative feedback it's like a very
targeted way to do this all in one
sitting
then there's all the quantitative stuff
so there's always metrics right
ultimately your KPIs and there's only
really four classes of metrics there's
like how many people use your stuff how
deeply do they use yourself how good is
it at doing the thing that you say it's
supposed to do and how much money do you
make
and all of your metrics basically roll
into those four and when you're building
features you just like mapping against
those things and you see whether those
numbers movement so between those two
you should you should be able to
triangulate like whether not a thing is
working thank you more time we're at
time a bit so I guess